oK we've just learned that at least part
of the reason potentially that the
ecuadorian embassy kicked WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange out of their
embassy in London was that they
confirmed that he was indeed connected
to Russian intelligence which by the way
should not come as a surprise to us we
actually suspected that for a long time
and it was confirmed by the Muller
report you might or might not remember
so let's reset you may recall that
Julian Assange spent years holed up in
the Ecuadorian Embassy in London to
avoid arrest and extradition eventually
we learned that the Ecuadorian Embassy
wasn't particularly thrilled with
Assange continuing to be there there
were ideas that his hygiene and
something about his cats or something
was at least part of the reason but
ultimately they told him that it's time
for him to go but we've now learned that
they were at least aware of another
factor on the basis of an investigation
that the Ecuadorian Embassy conducted
thanks to a Spanish investigation firm
which is something that Robert Muller
also told us and that is that Julian
Assange is tied to Russian intelligence
now the Muller report concluded this
already
WikiLeaks helped the Russians undermine
the United States election in 2016
Assange was effectively working with a
go-between between a WikiLeaks and
Russian intelligence and ultimately
Ecuador realized the exact same thing
they ended up hiring a Spanish company
to investigate Julian Assange their
report was obtained by CNN and it
includes information about at least 7
meetings in June of 2016 which was a key
moment in everything that was going on
with the Trump campaign and Russian help
there were a number of meetings in June
of 2016 that Julian Assange had with
Russians and others with ties to the
Kremlin five meetings with senior
staffers from RT that's the Russian
state television program and that
includes receiving a USB Drive from
Artie's London bureau chief Nicolai
Bogota Kian I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that name correctly so the
biggest news here is that this surprises
anybody because all along you know
Julian Assange would claim
all along that WikiLeaks is not
politically motivated in the sense of
partisanship they aren't for or against
any party or candidate they don't time
releases of information in order to have
any particular partisan political effect
but over time we started to see patterns
we started to suspect that that wasn't
the case
Assange's denial of a Russian connection
was really narrowly worded I'm going
from memory but Assange said something
like our source is not a Russian
government actor or something like that
which of course left open the
possibility that it was some kind of
informal actor or a go-between of some
kind that could have any nationality
that was functioning as a go-between
between Russian intelligence and
WikiLeaks and then Robert Muller figured
out that it actually was exactly in this
way despite it being relatively under
publicized you know when the Muller
report came out when the bar letter was
published the narrative that the
trumpets were pushing was no collusion
no obstruction they went on a national
exoneration tour and just talking about
the obstruction collusion stuff sort of
smothered the findings by robert muller
that a WikiLeaks was Russia connected in
this entire thing now there are some
people who are reacting and saying okay
this is just one instance where
WikiLeaks acted politically in cahoots
with Russia but basically WikiLeaks is a
nonpartisan actor and they don't make
decisions that are meant to favor any
particular people in power but certainly
not Russia that is very very wrong you
might recall that when WikiLeaks got the
leaks of those infamous Panama papers
those papers included information that
exposed corruption by Russian President
Vladimir Putin WikiLeaks refused to
publish those pieces and they publicly
even said Oh George Soros was involved
in fabricating the Putin stuff in order
to make him look bad so these are
partisan actors now you can say you
agree with their partisanship because it
aligns with your worldviews so you're
okay with it you still support what they
are doing but we've got to stop
attending that this is a nonpartisan
entity that doesn't time their releases
to have particular political impact that
doesn't make decisions on the basis of
political motivations to pretend that
they are nonpartisan actors is laughable
so don't fall for it except that there
are partisan actors and if you like what
they're doing defend their actions you
should be able to do that if you
actually believe that their actions are
motivated in good faith or that you
agree with their conclusions or partisan
position but stop saying that WikiLeaks
is not a partisan organization because
it is and all of the evidence that has
built up over the last I'd say four to
five years tells us very clearly that
that's the case if you disagree with me
I'm open to having my mind changed get
in touch please